[Music]
we are british telecoms uh we are one of
the largest uh uk network and television
telecommunications providers we also
operate globally across 880 different
countries um and
we work specifically in bt digital and
really we are focused on taking bt from
being a telco into a techo so it really
means transforming our core structures
and technologies including the drive to
cloud as option our key goals had to
align with moving away from our legacy
tightly coupled architecture with our
on-premise data warehouses and towards a
loosely coupled managed data mesh
architecture that'll enable new and
exciting value from our data each week
we'd have around 30 requests that had to
be provisioned and it would take an
engineer around three hours to do we
knew that with the varsity adoption gcp
about to begin with the business we had
to have a solution that could not only
react to the potential hundreds of hydro
requests but also react this demand to
build the project as soon as possible
for a team of only four engineers this
is a huge undertaking that we had to do
within three months
our devops philosophy really is a it's a
must-have it's a core belief it's
something we know we have to do we have
to be able to move faster we have to be
able to change quickly
to do that safely we need to use devops
we need to really understand it we need
to build measure learn and not just say
now we need to physically look at the
metrics we're producing get that
continuous feedback loop and devops is
at the core of everything we do within
bt we reached out to collaborate with
the google cloud team of tams and
engineers to ask them if some of the
problems that we faced that had been had
elsewhere
we were put into contact with an
engineer who helped give us a jump start
solution and with that we saw the
ability to see what was possible and how
we could quickly redevelop and expand
that into the solution it is today
it was interesting to see the true
limits for automation in 24 hours
managed to create 1 000 projects using
automation in order to handle the surge
request that came as a result of gcp
adoption in bt we'd like to you know say
say thank you to google first for for
the technology and then the work we get
to do
i'd like to say a big thank you to my
squad you know you've met dan and ryan
here but we also have another engineer
um who's been supporting us and a new
joiner recently joined the team too
we're not doing something small here
we're migrating the largest customer
database in the uk and we've got so much
value to find and bt has tens of
thousands of analysts and data
scientists ready to go
and this automation is what's going to
give us the speed and efficiency to
enable them to get a hold of our data